my name is chris kraus i'm currently the
chair of the classics department
at yale that said i'm now going to back
off
and introduce you to the introducers the
two
faculty members who are organizing the
series currently
beginning with my beloved former
colleague irini parano garrison
who is currently the pope professor of
latin at harvard if you can believe it
so irenae
good afternoon everyone it's such a
pleasure to see
uh the community gathered to hear
shelley haley today
um thank you chris uh and also to my
co-organizer yesha for
inviting me back for this momentous
occasion
i want to tell you a little bit about
the background to this lecture
it was the spring of 2018
when ayasha and i were asked i believe
by emily greenwood at that point
to take over the organization of the
parry lectures after
uh our colleagues uh chris krauss and
david quint had quite a long
stint in that position and as
ayesha and i began plotting a a
a strategy and a course for the parry
lectures
um it became became immediately clear to
us
that race was a topic that was
ubiquitous and bubbling beneath the
surface in so many conversations and
encounters
that we were having with students and
colleagues but a
topic that at that point wasn't present
enough in academic discourse and
frameworks
that we were encountering in our work in
pre-modern studies
certainly at yale how to talk about uh
race from a historical perspective how
to draw from critical frameworks
in ways that are sensitive to the
specificity of the pre-modern world
and above all a topic that is very dear
to us
how to weave scholarly narratives and
perspectives in and out of reflections
on embodied identities
in the here and now this all seemed
really pressing questions to us
at the time we were immediately drawn to
shelly haley's exemplary investment in
all of these questions from angles that
are at once scholarly deeply political
but also deeply personal
and you will all might immediately
recognize in particular trailblazing
work on
penny jackson copying and other black
women classes
and other seminal contributions on
translation race and the classics that
i'm sure my colleague aisha will mention
momentarily
we initially planned this lecture for
march 2020
but as we all know uh back then uh we
were in the grips
of the epidemics um
and we were forced to postpone we could
not have predicted a year or even two
years ago
that the summer of civil unrest and
awakening
that we experienced last year after the
murder of george floyd and that of so
many others
made the questions all the more pressing
and avoiding those questions
uh unconscionable frankly we're grateful
to professor haley for accepting the
original invitation
and we're so excited for the opportunity
that this unavoidable uh postponement
provides us
to engage with her groundbreaking work
and learn from her unique personal voice
so thank you and on to you aisha
thank you and this is one of those
lectures where there is a chain of
introductions which
uh is is no less than what i think uh
shelley haley certainly deserves
uh before i i do the the ritual
formality of introduction i do want to
uh point briefly to an extension of what
rene uh began to talk about which is the
intersection of voice
critical subjectivity and the nature of
our scholarship uh the pari lecture in
classics and comparative literature
speaks to a very wide range of scholars
those not just in classics but those of
us who
draw on and are adjacent to and
engage variously with the work in
classics in comparative literature and
other literary and
humanities disciplines at large i want
to begin by noting that shelly haley's
work
first came to my attention not for her
work as a classicist but because i was
teaching
a course in global shakespeare's and i
wanted to find
an essay that would introduce my
students to the challenges of reading
shakespeare's cleopatra
and the essay that i assigned regularly
now is
shelley's classic essay from the early
90s black feminist thought and the
classics
an essay that blew open my students
minds
um not only for its careful
uh working through of the manner and
mode of scholarship on a complicated
subject like cleopatra
but also for its ownership of her own
position
as a scholarly subject as a student as a
member of many complex overlapping
communities
and it is that voice that i think has
reached scholars
across a very wide range of disciplines
and that i certainly and i know many
others here today are excited
to hear uh so by way of introduction i
would actually like to start with some
words uh that shelly herself has written
which i think
are particularly crucial for our own
moment today as we begin
uh this barry lecture quoting patricia
williams uh shelley haley writes in that
uh seminal essay black feminist thought
in the classic um
and this is williams my attempts to
write in my own voice have placed me in
the center of a snarl of social tensions
and crossed boundaries
and reflecting on that quote shelley
writes think of the possibilities in my
case
feminist classicist and woman classicist
black classicist and black woman's
classicist
and black feminist and black feminist
classicist
if oxymoronic odds come in degrees i
would be somewhere near the high end
how did i come in this location as a
black feminist
classicist i welcome shelly haley here
both for her extraordinary uh
career she is currently the president of
the society for classical studies
um and she is edward north chair of
classics and professor of africana
studies at hamilton college
professor haley earned her ba from
syracuse university in 1972
she received her ma in 1975 and her phd
in 1977
both from the university of michigan an
expert on the figure of cleopatra she
has lectured widely on increasing the
representation of students of color in
latin ancient greek and classics
classrooms
and on her research about the role of a
classical education
in the lives and careers of 19th century
college-educated black women
her publications include fanny jackson
coppin's reminiscences of school life
and hints on teaching 1995
and numerous articles on the role of
women in the ancient world
and on race in the discipline of
classics in 2017
she received an award for excellence in
teaching at the collegiate level
from the society of classical studies
it's with enormous admiration
and uh a certain amount of modeling
uh and exemplary uh that i welcome
shelley haley to give the barry lecture
welcome professor haley
thank you so much thank you um
it's it's an absolute honor to be here
um i would like to start first with a
land acknowledgement
i respectfully acknowledge the oneida
nation of the hodo
ho den no shoni their elders
both past and present as well as future
generations
this acknowledgement demonstrates
solidarity
and commitment to the beginning of the
process of dismantling
the ongoing legacies of settler
colonialism i'd like to thank
the the departments of comparative
literature and
classics for inviting me to deliver the
perry lecture i
really am uh beyond honored um
to do this and i want to give a special
shout out to aisha
and irani for persisting
with with the invitation um you you both
have been
wonderful contacts and and great models
for
um how to um
treat gas that you invite um
to give a lecture um
before i begin um i wonder if we could
just have a moment of silence
um for the victims of gun violence
especially colorado and especially
the eight victims in georgia six of whom
were asian women
thank you
one of the most frustrating questions
i have received throughout my career is
which oppression has hindered you more
in classics
racism or sexism
the prestiant work of the com kumbaki
river collective in their statement
and the advent of critical race feminist
theory has helped me and other black
indigenous women of color
formulate responses which deconstruct
such questions
and reconstruct reconstruct the totality
of our lived experiences
one such reconstruction is the concept
of
racialized gender in discussions about
systemic
oppression the broader framework of
racialized gender can be specified
as gendered racism or
racialized sexism but today
i will be working within the broader
concept
of racialized gender when discussing
ancient hellenic and roman societies
our reception of race and gender in the
ancient world is situated within
the frameworks we employ knowingly or
unknowingly to analyze
these societies in recent years
feminist scholars and scholars of race
studies
have abandoned the approaches of
positivism
and turned to those of social
construction
and intersectionality
the term intersectionality was coined by
the legal scholar
kimberly crenshaw in her 1989
article the marginalizing the
intersection of race and gender
a black feminist critique of
anti-discrimination
doctrine feminist theory and anti-racist
politics
i love that title because it's so
victorian you know how victorians give
really long times
anyway however
as a concept it is rooted in the earlier
1977 kambahi river collective statement
authored by barbara smith beverly smith
and demeter fraser the statement was one
of the clearest
articulations of the simultaneity
of oppressions that women of african
descent
in particular suffer since crenshaw's
articulation
intersectionality is spread as an
analytical tool
beyond disciplines and borders
intersectional projects and methods
exist in a wide range of fields from its
original
jurisprudence sociology and education
to history psychology and even business
very few theories have generated the
kind of interdisciplinary and global
engagement that marks the intellectual
history
of intersectionality yes okay
intersectionality is a critical
intervention
against the essentialism of critical
race theory
and is a core concept of critical race
feminism
hereafter crf the anti-essentialism
of crf has according to one scholar
quote provided a critique of the
feminist notion
that there is an essential female voice
that is that all women feel one way on
the subject
crf highlights the situation of women of
color
whose lives may not conform to an
essential norm end quote
increasingly scholars of the ancient
world are finding intersectionality a
useful tool
to examine ancient societies but in a
limited way
often classes neglect the core
axis of race in their application
of the concept for some time
now the concept of social construction
has proved fruitful
in the efforts to uncover the social
constructions of race and gender
which operated in ancient societies
adrian catherine wing notes that social
construction
thesis helps us realize that quote
biological races do not exist
as recent science has clearly shown
there is more genetic difference within
so-called races than between them
instead races have been socially
constructed
and the legal system reifies that
construction privileging some races
over others end quote the same analysis
applies to genders and the intersection
of race and gender a sterling example
of the social construction of race in
the united states
comes to us from ta nahisi codes
and i quote but race is the child
of racism not the father
and the process of naming the people
has never been a matter of genealogy
and physiognomy as much as one of
hierarchy
this difference in hue and hair
is old but the belief in the
preeminence of hue and hair the belief
that these
factors can correctly organize as
a society and that they signify
deeper attributes which are indelible
this is the new idea at the heart of
these new people who have been brought
up
hopelessly tragically
to believe that they are white
end quote while both these
modern approaches can get us
closer to understanding what tim
whitmarsh has described as
hybridized ancient greek and roman
worlds
they still are flawed by exclusive
binaries that is either or
inherited by western epistemological
frameworks
and arguably first expressed by
aristotle
for race recasting whitmarsh's
concept of hybrid hybrid hybridization
as creolization is a first step
in dismantling these binaries
furthermore such reframing aids in
breaking down the influence
of modern social constructs of race and
gender
which undergirds our reception and
perception of race and gender
in antiquity for gender
the construct goes back to the 19th
century
when the rise of eugenic movements and
the cults of true womanhood
were the scaffolding upon which the
gender
construct was based
this the concept of racialized gender
provides i think
a fruitful way of discussing the
intersection of race and gender in
antiquity
up to now it has been marxist
feminists who have applied the concept
to
labor movements and labor history
where the intersection of race gender
and class
has been paramount to the discussion
however the broader parameters of the
concept
can apply trans-historically
to antiquity as eileen boris
states quote race and gender
exists in tandem to transform profoundly
the ways that each works alone
constructed through gendered
representations
race in turn reconstructs gender
identities
the concept of racialized gender
reflects the interaction
furthermore boris shows that racialized
gender
aids in dismantling the simplistic
binary
that men have race women
have a gender end quote
so how would this very modern
concept work when applied
retrospectively
to ancient hellenic and roman societies
let's go on a journey and examine three
case studies
so to speak medea
cleopatra and sophomore
this entails taking a broad view of race
to break out of the traditional binaries
in coded language
that is using ethnicity in place of race
in kate in these case studies i try to
stress
that the perception and reception of
women
and men is influenced by racialized
gender
i hope to show that the intersection of
race and gender in antiquity
reflects the transformational nature of
racialized gender
that boris described in the in the quote
above
before discussing the details of the
intersection of race and gender in the
ancient world
it is important to set out the operating
principles
of the discussion first and foremost
social constructs of race and gender
existed in antiquity
but they were not the same
as modern times but nevertheless
they existed however it cannot be
stressed enough
that the reception of the ancient
constructs of race and gender
in later times is profoundly
influenced by the hierarchical framing
described by coats and others
pushing against that framing to arrive
at a more plausible analysis
of race and gender in antiquity is the
intellectual
and moral imperative of this
lecture
ancient formulations of race and gender
like their modern counterparts were not
static nor were they immutable
jonathan hall notes this in his work on
what he calls ethnic groups i would call
them races but he calls them ethnic
groups
in hellenic society quote
ethnic groups are not static or
monolithic
but dynamic and fluid their boundaries
are permeable to a degree
and they may be subject to processes of
assimilation
and differentiation end quote
while we can argue that there were
relatively
uniform roman constructs of race and
gender
we cannot say that there were monolithic
constructs
in ancient hellenic societies
these were tied closely to various
demographic groups in different
city-states
around the aegean so as far as possible
i'm going to refer to the city-states by
name the hellenic peoples
enshrined different racial categories in
their mythic foundations
in this regard the narratives concerning
racial genealogies
are forms of social construction as
ancient societies strive to explain
their racial differences through a
shared ancestry
in the myths surrounding the genesis of
hellenic
peoples the ancestors of the three
major racial groups are depicted as
descendants of zeus
or helen iolis
doris and ion became the abominus
founders of the
aeolian dorian and ionian races
each race also shared linguistic and
cultural traits
it is in the latter sphere that the
intersection of
race and gender is clear
the ionian people best represented by
athens
constructed gender and gender relations
along rigid lines
especially after the legislation of so
long
in the 6th century bce
given the importance of racialized
gender for the construction of the
identity for hellenic peoples
it is not surprising to find it
illustrated in cultural production
especially literature this brings us to
medea
a mythic character who has become the
epitome
of racialized gender she is best known
to us from euripides's tragedy
medea and nearly all the receptions of
that play
from seneca to toni morrison focus
on the trope of the mother who kills her
own children
but what did euripides know he
undoubtedly knew
medea as the daughter of iets
of colcus as the niece
of cersei and so the granddaughter
of helios he was familiar with the
coronthiaka
now lost an epic poem which described
the death of medea's children
in the temple of hera other versions of
the story
portray the corinthians as the murderers
of the children as retribution
the corinthians were forced to establish
a hero cult for the children
in the 5th century bce the stain of
infanticide
still haunted the corinthians and so
they can
commissioned euripides to re-vision
the myth in euripides hands
medea becomes the foreign woman
extraordinaire
yet the description of medea as
foreign math has a way of
masking her racialized gender
so beyond divine genealogy
how did euripides read
medea's racial ancestry
herodotus informs us that kolkats was
colonized by the egyptian
pharaoh cestritis probably cesaros the
second
herodotus states and i quote the
egyptians did
however say that they thought
the original kokkians were men from
army my own idea on the subject
was based first on the fact that they
have black skins and woolly hair
not that that amounts to much that other
nations have the same
and secondly and more especially
on the fact that the kolkans the
egyptians
and the ethiopians are the only races
which from ancient times practiced
circumcision and quote
now this information from harada this
comes in
within the context of the construction
of peoples
other than hellenic as a barbarian
that's corroded this is word with this
knowledge in hand
euripides then establishes medea as
racially and
culturally other and sets her up as the
foil
to jason's racialized gender
one that is constructed as more
civilized
and hence superior your
european revision has had such
sustaining power because it resonated
with the later internalized
negative perceptions of the racialized
gender particularly
of women of african descent
in jason's soliloquy after the
infanticide
he declares that quote no woman
born in a hellenic society would ever
have gone through with such a crime
and later in the same passage he invokes
animal
and monster imagery a lioness
not a woman you more cruel in nature
than the etruscan
flash forward to the 19th through 21st
centuries
we black women have been masculinized
declared unfit mothers and portrayed as
not just
angry but full of rage
yet what gets largely ignored
is that jason cannot succeed without
medea's knowledge and skills
and even after the murder of her
children
she not the corinthians
buries her children and establishes a
cult in their honor
it is notable that in your liberties is
medea it is the chorus of corinthian
women who express the injustice
of women's position in euripides as
athens
these female members of the aeolian
demographic
demonstrate a different construction of
gender when they reflect
on the historical treatment of women
it is the thoughts of men
which are deceitful their pledges
which are loose the stories of women
shall now
turn our condition into a fair one
so that our lives shall achieve proper
glory
new value is coming for female kind
no longer shall slanders pollute our
story
the poems of long ago bards shall no
more
portray us as fickle untrustworthy
friends
bias because apollo for bore
to implant his lyrics in feminine
minds i tried to do that as a wrap
but it wasn't working so my apologies
um despite this plea for equality
of representation in literature and
history
the medea the play concretizes
the binary between foreign-born
and native women in the hellenic male
consciousness now before discussing
racialized genders constructed by the
romans
we need to establish the gender norm
just as in the united states when we say
african american men
we mean black men i'm sorry when we say
african americans we mean black men
and when we say americans we mean white
men
so for the romans romani meant roman men
roman masculinity racialized
gender in and of itself was the
norm in the text of roman literature
roman society was patriarchal and
androcentric
the authorship of the texts we'll look
at
being all male reflects that
gender difference is filtered through a
male
lens and that lens is the framework
for gender difference it's like a
circular argument
racialized gender was central to the
founding of rome
from whatever starting point one takes
whether the legends of aeneas or
those of his descendants romulus and
remus
the intersection of race and gender
formed the foundation of rome's origins
the julia claudians the founding dynasty
of the roman empire claimed
ancestry of the god venus furthermore
the romans constructed a national
identity
upon the trojan hero aeneas as a son of
venus
he imparted to the romans have shared
ancestry with venus
any discussion of racialized gender as
it appears in the literary production of
the augustine age
would be remiss without explicit
attention paid
to cleopatra's southern of egypt
cleopatra was the inspiration for
virgil's reception of dido
in the aeneid and as we will see for
livy's recalling
of the story of self-amoeba
the intersection of cleopatra's race and
gender
was paramount paramount to the treatment
of the historical
cleopatra received from prominent romans
such as cicero
and augustus as octavian
consequently it should be no surprise
that this intersection
weighed heavily on the literary
imagination of the writers of the
augustine period
after all cleopatra embodies the
racialized gender
which pervades all the fears of the
roman
ruling class men a foreign woman with
political power
in the geopolitical area which
historically
produced rome's most tenacious and
feared
rivals hannibal and cleopatra
so how does cleopatra fare in the rome
roman and rome identified
authors who dominate the source material
and who write their accounts one
to two centuries after she died
let's look at the two major ones
plutarch and cassius style
both of whom wrote their works in greek
and both of whom
embed their discussions of cleopatra
within the life stories of the men
plutarch especially capitalizes
on cleopatra's racialized gender to draw
a portion of cleopatra
as a highly educated wiley
seductress who becomes the ultimate
femme fatale for the roman men
she encounters he never
gives cleopatra an explicit
physical description relying instead on
intangible qualities such as
the timber of her voice
these intangibles come across as
enchanting and her ability of
molding her personality to her
prey conjures up the shape
shifters and tricksters of mythology
nothing in plutarch's description
leads us to believe cleopatra was or
is worthy of our trust
nor was she worthy of the romans
he highlights cleopatra's racialized
gender by comparing her
to the ideal represent
representative of roman racialized
gender
octavia
again there is no explicit
physical description for octavia
the sister of octavian who is
uh who was later called augustus as we
all know after
cleopatra committed suicide
what does plutarch say about octavia now
i
i have things bolded in my script here
so i'm going to try to like emphasize
with my voice
so you know what i have bolded
all right octavian this is pluto
octavian was very fond of his sister
who it is said he doesn't know right
just just to be clear he doesn't know
all right
who it is said was a
marvel of a woman
she was a widow having been married to
gaius
marsalis who had recently died
anthony too was considered a widower
now that folia had died
he that is anthony did not deny his
involvement with cleopatra
but did not call it marriage
though he still wrestled against
wrestled against his love for the
egyptian woman
everyone supported this marriage to
octavia
in hopes that she since she
had dignity and intelligence
in addition to considerable beauty
might support and be loved by anthony
as was fitting for such a woman
and that she would represent the
salvation
and harmony of all their affairs
in 35 that's the end of plutarch in 35
bce
acadia arrived in the east with supplies
for anthony's war against parthia
and according to many historians
octavian latvian agreed to this trip
in the hopes that anthony would
disrespect his sister
by staying with cleopatra in egypt
instead of going to athens and octavia
according to plutarch upon her arrival
in athens
octavia received a letter from anthony
who ordered her to remain there
but she though she was upset
and saw through anthony's pretext
nevertheless wrote to inquire where he
would like her to send the things
she was bringing him
and a friend of antony was sent
to deliver this message to him
and he the friend brought along with it
justified and appropriate praises of her
that is octavia
cleopatra perceived that octavia
was advancing on her and
feared that if octavia added to her
decorum
and caesar's power the pleasure of her
company
and her support of anthony she would be
untouchable and would have total command
of her husband
so cleopatra feigned
passionate love for anthony
and made her whole body waste away
with a strict diet
that's the end of pluto plutarch
mentions
how cleopatra employed lobbyists that's
my word
with anthony to scold him and call him
out for being quote
for being a quote harsh unfeeling
destroyer of a woman who was depending
on him
and him alone and quote
they declared that octavia had a brother
and quote enjoyed the name of wife
and quote the poor cleopatra
who ruled over many had to be content
with being called quote anthony's
mistress
and she did not avoid the term or think
it beneath her
provided that she could see him and
live with him and quote
and it worked anthony was persuaded that
cleopatra
might harm herself and he delaying his
journey to parthia
returned to alexandria octavia
returned to rome where according to
plutarch
quote she seemed too octavian to have
been mistreated
and he ordered her to leave anthony
unquote
in keeping with her ideal status she
refused to leave her husband's house
we all know the story right she stayed
and she
raised all those kids there were like
eight of them
i mean come on lady you're out you're
nuts but anyway
um she refused to leave her husband's
house
and begged her brother quote to discount
some things that had happened to her
since it would be intolerable if the two
most
powerful rulers sent the roman people to
war one
for the love of a woman and the other
to avenge a relative
end quote i don't i
i don't think i would have liked octavia
myself but that's okay
at least based on on plutarch here
she remained true and loyal to her work
and carried on activism on behalf of
anthony
plutarch concludes the episode
and i quote in this way she
inadvertently
harmed anthony as he was
hated for wronging such
a woman
cassius daya writing around 202 of the
common era
composes a fictitious speech for
octavian
to exhort troops to war and to justify
his declaration of war
on cleopatra in all there
in it there are all sorts of dog
whistles
for racialized gender dio has his
octavian draw upon roman history and
roman military pride with statements
such as
indeed for us as romans
rulers of the largest and
best part of the world to be disparaged
and
downtrodden by an egyptian woman
is unworthy of our fathers
yeah okay and then he goes on to list
all the great roman victories of the
past
octavian continues this exhortative
invective
quote who would not lament
to hear that roman knights and senators
fawn over cleopatra like eunuchs
who would not moan to hear and see
anthony himself
twice a council and many times a
commander
who would not weep to see that he is now
left behind his ancestral customs
that he has imitated the foreign and
barbaric ones
that he does not respect the laws and
gods of his ancestors
but bows before that woman like
isis or celine names her children
helios and fellini and finally
calls himself osiris and dionysus
oh
octavian continues the diatribe saying
that
at first he was sympathetic to anthony
even married his sister to him
and that quote i did not wish to go to
war with him because he insulted my
sister
or because he did not care for the
children he had with her
or because he honored the egyptian woman
instead of her
i considered the first reason to be that
the same approach should not be taken
with both cleopatra and anthony
for she was clearly an enemy
because of what she did and also because
she was a
foreigner but he as a citizen
might possibly be reasoned with
unquote octavian goes on to say that
anthony's rejection
of octavian's favors
proves that he is quote either
irrational
or insane for i have heard this
and believe he is under
that abominable woman's spell
and octavian blames anthony for bringing
another war to the romans
quote since he is enslaved to that
woman octavian
isn't finished therefore
let no one consider him a roman but
rather an egyptian
let no one call him anthony but rather
serepion it is not possible
for someone living in royal luxury
and being treated like a woman
to think and act like
a man
so in a nutshell cleopatra signifies
a bad woman she is dehumanized
and so she can become the scapegoat for
octavian's
war once octavian becomes
prime caps and augustus it would appear
that whenever a roman author
wanted or needed a negative
exempleum for womankind a pops a
cleopatra-esque
character for virgil it's tito
for livy it's sophonieba the daughter of
a carthaginian noble
has jubal is go
in the genre of historiography
there is one episode in libby's
narration
of the second carthaginian war that
lends itself
to the analysis of through
racialized gender and offers insight
into the racial ruptures
of roman history livy's
tragedy so to speak of sofiniba
delineates the racialized gender not
only
of roman men but also that of men
and women of african descent
further the character of sophomore
can be seen as the crucible for the
formation
of racial and gender identities
for the roman men um
sorry for for the roman male elite in
the age of augustus
therefore roman racial formation and
racialized gender formation
are constructed on the bodies of two
exotic others sophomore
and masonism the result then
is a social reproduction of ideal roman
masculinity
through the transformation of
masonissa's
racialized gender from that
of a numidian to that of a roman
however none of this is possible without
sophomore
who undertakes an equally transformative
racial and gender performance moving
from a cleopatra-esque
figure to a lucretia-esque one
that is from african to roman
mirroring as well as enabling the
performances
of a anissa
i'm going to do my best to give you a
summary of the story but it's a bit
twisted and so bear bear with me
um if you want to make a little chart of
all the main characters um
you can do that but it gets a little
involved
all right um so
the prominent sources for first off and
eva are polybius who never
names her and olivier who who gives the
most fulfil account
okay so sofiniba was the daughter of the
carthaginian leader
has drubal the son of gizgo
to distinguish from has jubal
uh barca the brother of hannibal
in a cultural tradition very similar
it's familiar
no doubt to the romans sophomore was
betrothed to massanissa okay
south africa was betrothed to messinissa
um who was the son of the leader
of the eastern numidians okay so numeria
is going to be
divided into two kingdoms there's the
the east and the west um
uh right so she's
engaged to masonissa um as a way
to cement a diplomatic alliance between
the eastern numidians
and carthage right but before they can
wed
a series of broken alliances and
political crises ensue
sea facts the leader of the western
right um new midians and an ally of rome
was able to conquer eastern
new media
um and at that point massanissa
switched his alliance to rome
okay has drubal now needs a new numidian
alliance
and so he marries sophomore
to see sax
the king of western numedia
forcing sea fats to break his alliance
with rome
so masonissa goes to rome stefans
leaves rome goes to carthage that's
the alliance picture in a nutshell
um when the romans invaded
uh africa under the command of scipio
and leilas
they with the help of massanissa
were able eventually to defeat sea facts
and has drugal after masanissa
captured pierta uh cfax's capital
he impulsively married self-amoeba
to prevent her from falling into roman
hands
when yes in this
the property of rome massanessa sent
poison to his wife in heroic fashion
she drank it and died
now you probably didn't
realize this already the story is
much more complex and nuanced than
even that kind of complicated summary
can relate for instance
each of the two significant ancient
sources for the story of south ameba
relies on racialized gender gender
stereotypes
in the characterization of sofoniba
masonissa and setax
for instance polybius relates that
scipio
thought it likely that cfax was bored by
his young bride
who he never names and hence by his
alliance with the carthaginians
the reason polo libius attributes to
scipio for thinking this
is what's important here for polybius
says it was because and this is a quote
of the natural fickleness
of the numidians and their perfidy
towards gods and men
polybius does give a hint of sofoneva's
charming and
persuasive personality in this section
sofiniba is
begging sea facts not to deserve the
carthaginians
and she is moved by his injuries
livy is the source who spends the most
time on south amiibo
we learned from him that sofiniba
was a maid of marriageable age
that and libby describes how has drubal
took advantage of her beauty and charm
and of steve axe's passion
to bind the numidian leader more closely
to the carthaginian cause
libby's portrayal of sophomore is taken
up
when again when masanissa
captures kirta
matanissa is spotted by south ameba
now named by libby who begs
the dominion leader to save her from the
romans
in the act of naming her libby gives
self anima not only agency but also
accountability
she is no longer the dutiful nubilus
weirgo
doing her father's bidding she is now
she now has the potential to act in her
own name and on her own behalf
captivated massanissa agrees to help her
and impetuously marries her
none of this is pleasing to scubia who
pedantically demonstrates to masinissa
that sophomoriba is the property of rome
and he must turn her over to him
massanisso like the good student of
roman ideals that he is
goes off to consider the advice and
admonition of scipio
and resolves to send sofiniba a cup of
poison
which she bravely accepts
now all of the later sources give notice
of soft and eva's beauty and education
noting that she was well versed in
grammar and music
these authors go on to say that she was
clever
ingratiating and all together so
charming that the mere sight of her
or the sound of her voice
who does that sound like suffice
to vanquish everyone even the most
indifferent
these later sources no doubt
because of their distance from the
events of the late roman republic
make the conflation with cleopatra more
explicit
than libby needs to nevertheless
the similarity between sofinibas and
cleopatra's
racialized gender is particularly
striking
whereas the later sources seem to be
telling a touching story
livy's agenda is very different
reestablishing
the roman moral fabric of old
one which has become badly frayed
his main vehicle for this is racialized
gender
as a result each of the male characters
has his own political and or moral
crisis
occurring and each crisis gets resolved
by reasserting the normative
racialized gender for instance
earlier in book 29 libby describes
scipio's crisis surrounding the
subjugated city of lokri
in magna gracia there had been a
senatorial investigation it
kind of sounds like today you know every
time something goes wrong there's a
senatorial investigation um into the
complaints of the
locker rooms and scipio's role in them
libby recounts the following charges uh
revealed during the senate's
deliberations
much was also said against the
commander-in-chief himself mrs scipio
his dress and bearing were on roman
if not and not even soldierly
he strolled about the gymnasium in a
greek mantle
and sandals and wasted his time
over oh my god books and physical
exercise
i'm sorry for the editorial insert there
the discipline of the whole army had
gone to the dogs
so that it was more of a menace to his
its friends than its enemies
now while many or even most of these
charges were untrue
scipio does have an image problem
and he must reclaim both his moral
position as the exemplar of the ideal
roman
of ideal roman masculinity as well as
its political reputation
as a military commander masanissa and
self-amoeba are the tools
to his success in this reclaiming
when masonissa conquers kierta and
defeats c-facts
he is an ally of scipio and becomes his
proxy
in terms not only of military success
but also roman racialized gender
however livy makes very clear that
massenissa is racially different
to the romans he is emulating
southama is a vehicle through which livy
reminds us
that our numidian hero is a non-roman
hero the beautiful carthaginian woman
will seduce him and cause him to slip
back into his natural
racialized gender and stereotype of the
numidian
let's look at what happens
when livy first mentions sophomore it is
clear that has dribble her father
is the architect of the scheme to win
oversea facts from the romans
sofiniba is a pawn in a political move
has drupal is relying on his daughter's
beauty and sea sax's
passionate nature however
when self-aniva is the agent of her own
destiny
and comes out to greet masonissa
livy gives her a speech that
demonstrates
that she has the perfect pervasive sorry
persuasive power to obtain whatever she
wants
as well as the racial rupture
caused by the roman invasion of africa
this is south amoeba according to libby
if i had been nothing other than the
wife of
cfx i would have preferred to trust
the honor of a numidian and one born
like me in the same africa
than that of an alien an outsider
what a daughter of carthage not to
mention
a daughter of has drubal has to fear
from a roman you do understand
if you are able of nothing else then i
beg and beseech you to save me through
death
from the romans will
livey overshadows sofiniba's appeal
to masonis's race loyalty
by again repeating the racial stereotype
as he livy relates the scene
after sofiniba's speech he describes her
as outstanding in beauty
and at a blooming age
from livy's perspective massanissa
heard sophomobia's speech more
as blandishments of a lover rather than
in treaties of a supplement
because he is a numidian and the race
of numidians is inclined
towards passion that is a quote from
libby
as a consequence libby says quote
the victor is captured by the love
for the captive the subsequent marriage
between sophomore and masinissa
also gives lily the context in which to
contrast
the recklessness of masonissa
and the self-control of scipio
livy focuses on scipio showing his
controlled handling of c
that's his defection as well as his
disappointment
and even anger over
mathematics yielding to his baser
instincts when responding to why he
turned
from his alliance with rome sea
that's places the blame on his having
wedded a carthaginian woman
it was madness bred from passion
more worrisome to scipio but
consistent with livy's view that lack of
restraint has unfortunate consequences
is c facts is observation that
massanessa was
neither more prudent nor restrained
than he in fact
massanissa is less cautious
because of his youth mass and this is
hasty impulsive marriage to sophomore
um supports cfx's image
of nasa nissa and provides the most
telling evidence to support
scipio's growing anxiety scipio sees
clearly the possibility
that massanissa although he's been very
loyal up to this point
might now turn to the carthaginian cause
due to the influence of self a nebo
in addition to his anxiety
scipio is disgusted disgusted
because following most mayoral
he practiced self-control and resisted
the beautiful female prisoners when he
was in spain
when messinissa arrives he scipio
receives him
warmly and lavishes public
preys on him for his military
accomplishments
there follows however a
a private tongue lashing
this is scipio but of these
virtues for which i would seem to have
been sought out by you
i should have been prouder of none as
much as my self-control
and my resistance to bodily lusts
how i wish that you had added this also
to your other outstanding virtues
masonissa
there is not absolutely not
believe me as much danger
to men of our age from armed enemies
as from the constant presence
of sensuality all around us
the man who reigns these in
and tames them with his own self-control
has earned for himself more honor
and a greater victory than we have
with the conquest of sea facts
oh my goodness he's a self-righteous
little
something in you all right levy
demonstrates
that massanissa passionate no numidian
though he may be is really more roman
than the romans
and shares many of their ancient values
however messimissa like livy's
contemporary romans
has lost sight of these virtues scipio's
exhortation to masonissa not to destroy
the many good qualities with the one
defect of passion
could well be livi's words to his fellow
romans
mass and this fully grasped the logic of
scipio's speech
and like many colonized people
is caught between two worlds
does he abandon the colonizer and lose
all the political advantages that might
flow
from that alliance or does he become a
race trader
and turn over the woman he loves to roam
after privately venting his grief he
hits upon a compromise
of sorts and provides himself aniba
with the opportunity to commit suicide
when she accepts the cup of poison she
reverts
back to her previous gender performance
of the obedient woman
by moving from a passive silent and
obedient daughter
to a forthright vocal agent of her own
sexual and political destiny
she violates the norm of roman
femininity
and becomes the cleopatra-esque exemplar
of the corrupting foreign beauty
when she accepts the poison she moves
back
to the obedient although certainly not
passive or silent wife and restores
order to the roman male
view of gender norms in the time of
living
the speech that libby gives sophomore as
she receives to the poison
places her in the tradition of lucretia
the noble roman woman who commits
suicide
for honor and i quote
i receive this wedding gift
one not unwelcome if a husband is able
to offer his wife
nothing greater but tell him this
i would have died a happier death
if i had not wed on the day of my
funeral
for this she earns praise from lily
quote she spoke calmly as she drained
fearlessly the received cup
with absolutely no indication of
trepidation
unquote even though scipio loses a
trophy to be paraded in his triumph
who does that sound like he gains so
much more because of self-amoeba
his crisis of masculinity is resolved
by the assimilation of an african man
who becomes a shining example
of roman racialized gender and by the
suicide of an
african woman whose beauty might have
just been
dismantled the roman imperial agenda
i hope i have shown that the
intersection of race and gender
succinctly expressed in the concept of
racialized gender
is a useful tool in analyzing the
ancient societies of hellenic and roman
peoples donna haraway
makes the argument that quote
neither gender nor race is something
with an origin
or example in the family
that then travels out into the rest of
the social world
rather gender and race
are built into practice
unquote this is as true
in antiquity as it is today
thank you very much
thank you so much shelly um
for that wonderful detailed talk and all
those great quotations
um uh the we will take questions how
professor haley will take questions now
i would invite everyone to
uh either put their name in the chat so
i can see you
and call on you since there are many
people on this uh call
or to simply put their question directly
into the chat
and i will relate quite i will read and
relay questions professor haley just to
make this uh smoother
um so uh shelley there are already uh a
few questions
and i'm gonna just um uh go through them
one by one uh so the first question you
have is
about uh the um what happens to the
biracial children of medea and cleopatra
and the questioner laura holland gold
goldweight notes um that both
sets of children are killed and she asks
have you noted instances of this kind of
hybridization
being considered monstrous somehow and
therefore such
offspring simply had to die
okay um
uh to the um the second question
about monstrosity right um
um yes and no
who was also biracial um he had to die
right but that was a political
calculation
that wasn't based on the fact that he
was biracial
right um i
the children of the twins for example
um alexander helios and cleopatra celine
seem to have had very happy lives um
after the the death of
their parents um i i i
it always amazes me that that's how it's
described
by um
folks um after all they they were
raised by octavia right she she
uh reared them um
we know that cleopatra celine went on to
become
a ruler in her own right with juba
ii um
and so uh um
from all accounts alexander was was
um as far as we can tell
certainly he adjusted better than
let's say caligula or nero um so
um he he he seemed to
to have a you know a fine life um
so i don't believe i mean i've never
read any negative descriptions
of biracial children
um in the sources
um so um
yeah uh it and and i think it's
because we're we're sort of dealing with
the same
class of people right we're
it's not like they're different class
statuses
here um so
um yeah
thanks um suzanne lai has a question
suzanne would you like to unmute
yourself
right can you hear me yes fantastic
uh thank you so much um it's great to be
here with everybody and thank you
shelley um
and i know we've talked about this a
little bit before because
you know i've always um and so in the
comics of i've always thought of like
race and gender is like sliding scales
that intersect
i think we've talked about that before
um
and my question for you like as i was
listening to your talk
was that you know it seems like or using
that word foreignness which seems to
keep coming up
um already implies female gender
in it um so even when it's used to
describe a man
it you know but whether man or woman
right it implies
no gender but it doesn't seem to work in
the other way
like so describing a woman that doesn't
necessarily
seem to or does it that's the question i
guess or does it seem to
like it it seems like one is more
distinctly pointing
you know towards the two whereas
if you say like if you look at a woman a
greek woman or a roman woman
and just describe her as a woman um does
that imply a foreignness to it
um hmm that's a really really great
question and and
the first thing that springs in my mind
is and i think it kind of supports your
point
that that um effeminacy
is implied in foreignness
right and that's when when jarvis
is praying to his father
um jupiter amman to to
um put an end to this affair
um between dido and
aeneas um the way that he describes
aeneas
right the description that he gives it
he calls him a semi-weir
right because i'm a semi-weir and he his
hair
is dripping with perfumed oils excuse me
um so everything is pointing to the fact
that he is not a man
right and the same with
that um invective that cassius style
makes up
about octavian right he says you know
anyone who is is um treated
or lives the life like of luxury like a
woman
shouldn't be called a man um so
yes i i i think it's true that it's
another
um it's another way
to be misogynistic right um
but i still think that um
yeah um it definitely the
the women get the
the shorter end of things
you rarely see
women well except in myth
right when women are masculinized
then they sort of become monsters right
yeah i was gonna ask that there seems to
be a monster scale somewhere
on here as well yeah that's right that's
right
that's right and so jackie murray has
talked about a bit too right
right um so yeah
um i mean racialized gender
at least modern
way i mean i i always try to
hope that things are a bit better in the
ancient world but that's not always
the case but certainly
racialized gender is meant to describe a
kind of oppression
and so um
it is true that that women um
are it it's it's not a positive
right the outcome of it is is never
positive
um and i think that's probably also true
in in antiquity especially if the woman
is also
foreign i mean it would be interesting
to look at
well let's see let's say phovia right
phobia violates every
whatever bullet point you want in terms
of roman femininity
fulvia violates those right and so
she gets described you know
i mean she is masculine right um
based on her actions the fact that she
leads an army
and she right um and what is it plutarch
says
at what boy he says cleopatra should
thank phovia
for um um training
um anthony to um
yield to the control of a woman or
something
um so it's yeah
yeah but that's a that's a really
i have to think about that that point
that it's it's a really interesting one
that it's still
womanhood isn't raised up because of
racialized gender it's still
considered um kind of the lower end of
things
right yeah yeah um thank you shelley so
here's another question from the chat
and i think this is a question that
you've um thought more about and alluded
to early on in your talk um
but the questioner asks uh you did
reflect further on the difference
between ethnicity and
race and suggests that uh greek was
perhaps a linguistic category and he
writes a lot of literature written in
greek after alexander was written by
people who were not born or raised greek
and that barbarians opposition greeks
were people who did not speak greek and
so i wonder if you can reflect
um on the question of kind of language
ethnicity and race and how you use the
word race and racialization
right um so
i just find um particularly
for those of us who want to be
careful and want to i don't
don't want to make a mistake or don't
want to say
the wrong thing or
that i i think in sometimes not always
but sometimes
ethnicity becomes a code word um
or or a euphemism when race would
work better right um i'm i'm thinking
particularly i i note that
um a lot of my
colleagues in a broad sense
that if they talk about race then
that makes them racist and the two
things are very different right um you
can talk about race
that someone is african-american
that doesn't make you racist right um
so i i absolutely agree i mean
let's just take latinx latinx is a
is a linguistic category right
so folks who are latinx
can can be white or they can be
of african descent right or they can be
asian
right so yes there there definitely
are linguistic categories
um i i have a problem the problem i have
with um with
with greek is is that you know when
we're talking about the greeks
right it's it's a little like um
the modern day um umbrella and and folks
here can correct me if i get this wrong
but the the modern day umbrella of
of asian right oh my goodness
i mean that's a huge category of people
right and so you you
you lose the the specificity
when you always talk about the greeks
well who who are you really talking
about
um i would say 95 of the time you're
actually talking about the athenians
um and so i mean the the spartans are
different
right absolutely that's the most obvious
group that who's different to the
athenians but
they're there were the lesbians there
were the corinthians
there were the all these get lumped in
under greek and and i don't want to lose
that's
that specificity um i i also want
us to um
really think about um
race less as something that's
physical and more something that's
cultural right um and that
too is problematic okay i because that
that opens it up to all sorts of things
like oh so
that means rachel rachel dojo was okay
and i'm going no no no no no no it's not
no
that's not okay no right but
but just to kind of what we have to do
is we have to break the stranglehold
of of the white supremacist
um bio um
racism that um
developed right that that's what i'm
trying to do
is to kind of break us out of that and
think more broadly
about what race could have been right
in antiquity right and it's hard i'm not
i'm suggesting at all but this is
easy right um and
yeah so shelley i'm going to exercise my
prerogative here as the moderator to
sort of wonder
with you as a non-classicist in my own
field which is early modern studies
uh the early model studies and medieval
cities have of course been roiled by
similar kinds of conversations about you
know how do we talk about race and one
one pretty strong answer coming out of
critical race theory has been to sort of
think about race
uh as a social category as about
modalities of hierarchization about
um forms of power and how they are
exercised
and to understand them less as being
inscribed on the body in a biological
sense which is of course
one one way in which race is conceived
in the 19th century primarily
but to explore uh the mechanisms of
social organization and race
as the term that names that so for
instance in the early modern period
historians have uh worked on the term
nazi right the idea nation
uh how is that in fact a racialized
category perhaps um
not perhaps race in the sense we might
understand it post
19th and 20th century but in a term that
carries that same charge of social
organization
and i wonder if that is helpful in the
classical context as well
um yes i mean i
just off the top of my head i would say
yes um
i think one thing that often
gets it kind of gets elided
is um the sense of class
um it's it's very easy i mean all of the
the people right even even media
for that matter even though she's
mythical um
the ringing in my head is what my
children would say to me
when when they were little and i was
sort of
struggling with these things and i was
going on i think it was dido i was going
on and on about and like
both my son and daughter would say to me
mom
mom come down they're fictional
so i don't want to invest too much media
but um
um no i forgot what i was gonna say
um oh they're the they're
all everyone i talked about right is of
the ruling class
every single one every single one and so
when you look at things like graffiti
right
the graffiti and pompeii that
yeah well what what does it mean when
someone
describes you know that they're in love
with someone
and and um she she happens to be
um um a black woman that's how she's
described negra right she's described as
a black woman
but the the candida woman which we're
not going to translate as
as um white um the candida woman is
jealous and gets angry about this
well you know we're not talking about
the ruling class now
we're talking about just sort of
everyday folks
um so um i
i think then i think the social
probably works i think if you get out of
the political class
and you're looking at sort of everyday
kind of folks
i think
definitely race is a social category
rather than um
the status that we have certainly works
i would say yeah shelly one more
question uh jeff
you should thank you thank you very much
uh thank you professor haley that was a
fascinating talk and it was so
wide-ranging i really enjoyed it i hope
i have let's say
a relevant question uh thanks to our
wonderful uh post-coveted world
a lot of us have been taking advantage
of seeing a number of talks that we
might not otherwise
get a chance to see including yours i
heard one last week which was very
interesting which is the construction of
race
in the early one of lombard
observations ethnicity is a better word
maybe uh
one of her observations uh also
similarly focused on
the association of male gender with
regards to themselves
but i was kind of curious about the
rhetorical exercise
of using barbarians and i use that put
that in quotation marks
to point out the feminine read weak
racial stereotypes in themselves and i
was thinking of things like tacitus
constructions of germanic identity or
procopius's constructions of ostrogothic
masculinity relative to
to romans etc and i guess my question
really is the degree to which
civilization is perceived as feminine in
these discourses
of course this well let's see
one way that folks
this is not me this goes
beyond me but but just in terms
of group identity right so group
identity formation
how do you determine
what your group identity is and i do
think this is trans-historical i think
this goes
across age asia um ages
how do you determine
who your group is right right
um there's a couple ways to do to do
that you you could do the both and
right you could say oh um my people
are all the people who wear who wear
headphones
um and who are on zoom those are my
people right
um so it's it's a series of ants it's
additive right or you can do
the exclusive right i determine
who i am by
checking off what i'm not
right and so i don't know if that's what
you're talking about but i think
you look you certainly um
establish the um
i'm going to break my own rule but the
ethnic identity
right of the greeks right
who does he pit them against
right does he say it's all the people
who eat olives
at lunchtime no
he pits them against the enemy
right who are the persians who do things
very different
today to them the same with his
description of the egyptians
oh my god the egyptians
like have sex outdoors
what they're they're they're barbarians
right or they pee outdoor whatever or
whatever he says the egyptians do
right so um yeah
it's it's it's if in the
the discourse of trying to
do right whether you want to call it
racial formation or
group identity formation if it's a
question of
insider outsider
then that you know and i think that's
the way most western societies have done
it
right um and maybe not just western
um certainly in any
society that um
has um i think about in my own family
um my great-grandmother was
a member of the onondaga nation right
which is
part of the haudenosaunee right so
but when when she married
outside of the nation as she did
right and it didn't matter who it was it
happened to be an african-american but
it didn't matter who it was she was no
longer a member
right of that group um
so that's the way they
formed their and still do their their uh
identification so um
yeah i don't know if that answers your
question jeff but
um i i think um
the the outsider the unknown the
foreigner
is always going to be portrayed as
the barbarian is ethnocentrism
in in in a nutshell right so
we're always superior heavens we are
right we're the best american
exceptionalism we're the best
right and that's okay
as long as there isn't value attached as
long as you don't go out and shoot
people
because right they're not american
right americans are only people who
eat apple pie and whatever um
i'm veering off into the silly now but
but
yeah so i hope that helps one final
question uh
tristan i'm gonna uh invite you to
unmute yourself in one second um
it's my friend tristan go ahead hi
tristan how are you
nice to finally um catch you i know the
last question i brought that up
beauty of the virtual world i finally
fantastic yeah tristan and i go way back
so one of my big influences
um but i'll be can try my best to be
concise so i have
two interconnected questions
do you see because you know when we have
that you know that issue with the race
ethnicity thing and i've sort of made
the same
observations you have within you know
egyptology
and you know study is you know in
classics
do you think also that there's a
relationship
between culture and race or an overlap
and the second thing that's intertwined
to that do you think
keep him i'm and i use race and racism
distinctively i make that distinction
do you think there's with roman
imperialism
that you can make an argument for racism
you know when during the roman empire or
as a basis of the roman empire i hope my
question makes sense and
that that's that's my two questions yeah
um okay so let me answer the second one
first um well let me ask no
nevermind um i
really struggle with this question about
race and culture
right um is it is it like chicken and
egg or is it
um
i think um
what what was the number one way
and whether we're talking about rome or
whether we're talking about
you know ancient hellenic societies or
or we're talking about
um modern day i guess right
what's the first thing you have to do
to make a slave
right but what's the first thing you
have to do
nobody wants to think about this nobody
wants to think about this
you strip them of their culture
you take them away from their culture
right so that would make
me think then if that's true and this is
happening
before there was color slavery
right right then
there's culture and then
later at some point right
or we can call cultural race right if
we're talking about
sort of pre-transatlantic slaves
trade or pre-color slavery um
and really i'm getting out of my
wheelhouse here so so bear with me
but but so you stripped someone of their
culture
right to dehumanize them to
to to right disassociate them
of what gives them power right
um so in that way
i mean i i think you could say they're
they're synonymous
right um so
um and a part of that is you know not
letting them have their own language
right right people that you want to
enslave
you you take away their
um the way they express
uh themselves you take away their
language you take away
the religion or the religious practices
you right you stifle
their their brains by not allowing them
to be educated
so yeah
now that that happened right that
you know look what the spartans did to
the helix
right that happened in the ancient
these ancient mediterranean societies
right um
[Music]
so um this
so the set what was the second question
again tristan i forgot
um it was about
racism and roman imperialism all right
yes this is a tricky one
i think oh this is it really it's a
tricky one
um
because the the in some ways the romans
were very
clever in that they didn't they didn't
strip people of their language they
didn't say everybody has it all that and
you know enforce them
into schools like we did the native
americans and
right so they didn't take away the
language they didn't
um but at the same time
they there was a kind of coerced
assimilation
so can we call that racism
right i i guess so
i mean i i don't
i don't know to be honest
i have to think about that one um
i i'm down with the imperialism
i'm down with sort of the
um the ethnocentrism
of the romans um
i'm just not sure whether i don't know
if it rises
to the to the um
i always use jim crow as though right
did the romans pass laws that said
that the ethiopians for example
um had to use separate water fountains
well no they didn't right they didn't
so yeah let me
[Music]
i think this might be a i think this
might be a good time to to release
shelley
um and uh and and thank her very much um
uh aisha and i were uh uh just saying
that we'd like to
uh invite if if this is okay with with
professor haley um those of you whose
questions didn't get answered may they
contact you
sure absolutely right absolutely no your
your email is on your
is on your hamilton website i think yes
and it's very easy it's just ask hayley
hamilton.edu because i know there were
some
i see my student lexi from all right
and i i know there are some there's some
students um from other places as well
right so let us let us thank professor
haley and
um and uh well and and say good night
you